in 1960 the u.s violent crime rate
started rising
and for three decades this was one of
the most vexing and
talked about problems in america anxiety
over the possibility of being a victim
is becoming an accepted part of everyday
life it's affecting the way people live
particularly in cities and towns that
were unaccustomed to the sphere before
by the early 1990s policymakers had
mostly lost
hope and then violent crime started
falling and it kept falling
meanwhile the number of incarcerated
americans continued to climb
it was the crime decline that made
possible a bipartisan movement to reckon
with the injustice of over-incarceration
and the failure of the war on drugs but
last year the united states
experienced the largest rise in
homicides in decades which could bring
the return of tough on crime rhetoric
and undermine the criminal justice
reform movement
critics say a recently elected group of
district attorneys in elite coastal
cities who are
dismissing routine property crimes and
failing to jail potentially dangerous
individuals
are exacerbating the problem this
backlash underscores why it's so
important to distinguish between
worthwhile criminal justice reform and
simply failing to enforce the rule of
law
join us in rejecting the notion that to
be free we must cage others
san francisco district attorney chaisa
boudin is among this new crop of
progressive prosecutors
he was raised by two famous left-wing
radicals of the 1960s bernadine doran
and bill
ayers and his biological parents were
imprisoned on felony murder charges when
he was a baby
stemming from their involvement with the
weather underground didn't make sense
that the state was willing to destroy my
family because of something my parents
did and they did it
they're not innocent this is not about
them being wrongly convicted
this is about what do we do with people
who actually commit crimes since boudin
took office in january 2020 burglary
arson
and murder have all spiked in san
francisco though rape
and assault rates have fallen and most
of his term has taken place during the
covet 19 pandemic a time when life in
the bay area has been
far from normal there is now a petition
to recall san francisco district
attorney
chasa boudin boudine is facing possible
recall
for failing to prosecute and jail a man
accused of several burglaries who then
drunkenly ran over and killed two women
and a man twice accused of domestic
abuse who then murdered an
infant victims want answers and we get
the same lip service
what is your response to them i will
continue to personally
do whatever it takes to provide justice
and safety
to the people of san francisco but can
other progressive da's strike a better
balance
as they reform the system i think that
the big lie was just basically that we
have convinced our community for years
that over incarceration and more police
presence and more prosecutions actually
was leading to
greater safety when in fact it has
probably led to greater insecurity
george gascon took office this year as
los angeles new district attorney
he's a former lapd officer and once held
the same job as boudin in san francisco
gascon defeated the more conservative
incumbent jackie lacy with his radical
reform agenda pledging to release up to
20 000 low-risk offenders
he immediately ended cash bail for
misdemeanors and what he calls
low-level non-serious crimes we saw
people that
were being held in pre-trial
incarceration for weeks and months on
end just simply because they couldn't
afford a very low
dollar amount to bail and they were not
necessarily dangerous so
the reality is that there is no
connection between how much money you
have in your bank account and whether
you're dangerous or not
since taking office gascon has made good
on his promise
not to prosecute victimless crimes like
low-level drug possession
and sex work but he's also declining to
prosecute actual property crimes like
trespassing
libertarians would tend to say you know
drugs should not be criminalized at all
but the government's primary role is to
protect
life and property so i mean is there a
case that
you should we should be even more
radical in decriminalizing drugs
while at the same time treating property
crimes more seriously
data has continued to flow and more so
recently that shows that
the criminal process when it comes to
low-level non-violent offenses actually
increases safety in general not just for
those types of crimes
but even for more serious crimes the
property crime rate jumped
nearly 40 percent during gascon's almost
nine-year tenure as san francisco's d.a
people will draw that connection and say
well look how much
property crime spiked under gascon in
san francisco
that's what's going to happen here in
los angeles what's your reply to that
the spike in property crime san
francisco was purely driven by car
breakings
gascon says local police retaliated
against him for co-authoring
california's prop 47 which reclassified
many felonies as misdemeanors
after prop 47 a lot of cops say we're
not going to enforce any of this stuff
anymore they were against it
they wanted to basically teach me a
lesson i finally started a task force
with the california highway patrol
and in several federal agencies we
actually
went after car break-ins at a time when
the san francisco police department
decided not to
and within about a year or so we saw the
decrease if you agree
that there should be some sort of
consequence for even
level offenses that reduce the quality
of life
of for people living in big cities what
should the consequences actually be well
i
i hate to even almost use the term
consequences because when people are
saying
because they don't have money to get
housing criminalizing that behavior i
think is
not only immoral i believe but it
doesn't fix the problem right so i would
say that rather than consequence i like
to use the term
you know the right intervention what are
the right interventions for that
population
quality of life crimes are not something
that you want to prosecute on every
instance
but you also don't want to have a
blanket policy
that prohibits you from ever prosecuting
them as well eric siddall
is the vice president of the la
association of deputy district attorneys
the prosecutor's union which sued gascon
for directing the da's office not to
pursue
extra harsh sentences for repeat felons
or in crimes involving gang members a
judge recently ruled
partially in their favor siddall says
the lada's office has been making
positive reforms for years and that
gascon
is disregarding public safety there has
to be a middle ground and i think that's
what our office was trying to do prior
to mr gascon
but when you have a blanket policy that
completely ignores
quality of life crimes then expect the
quality of life to decrease in those
neighborhoods
seven municipalities including the
beverly hills whittier and pico rivera
city councils have issued votes of
no confidence against gescon the la
sheriff has publicly supported a recall
siddhal worries that stripping
prosecutors of the ability to pursue
harsher sentences against gang members
will
set back the decades-long effort to stem
gang violence in a city once plagued by
it
he basically destroyed most components
of our office
and our ability to effectively prosecute
cases
the gang division has been around since
1978
and was one of the models for the rest
of the country on how to deal with
violent street gangs and one of the
first things he did was
he pretty much dismantled that unit and
redirected resources to other
projects that he has it's very clear
from his policies
his words and his deeds that he is not
terribly interested
in dealing with violent criminals here
in los angeles
but in recent years problems with la's
gang database have emerged after lapd
officers were charged with fabricating
gang affiliations of individuals they
pulled over
forcing prosecutors to review hundreds
of possibly tainted cases
gascon has also opposed long prison
sentences
even for the perpetrators of violent
crimes
data in the case of people as we get
older there's a less likelihood that
we're going to reoffend
while it's true that people are less
likely to commit crimes as they grow
older the data on the effectiveness of
long sentences
on deterring and preventing violent
crime is mixed
with one study of three strikes finding
that the policy significantly reduces
felony arrest rates another study from
the public policy institute of
california that looked specifically at
re-sentencing reforms
that saw the early release of many
prisoners found little evidence of a
relationship between more severe
sanctions and better recidivism
partially bolstering gascone's argument
the researchers unsurprisingly
discovered a significant drop
in drug reoffenders as the state
deprioritized drug offenses but a slight
rise in repeat offenders in more
serious categories like crimes against
persons
his data and science argument that he
uses
is baloney you're not going to have less
crime by letting
violent criminals out of prison you're
not going to have less crime
by not punishing people appropriately
you're not going to have less crime
by not penalizing someone from using a
gun
you're not going to have less crime by
basically saying we're going to give a
pass
to the gangs that's just not going to
work despite
his stated commitment to following the
data gascon isn't immune to political
pressure
he repealed his own order not to seek
long sentences for criminals who
victimized children or the elderly or
commit hate crimes
claiming that because trump had so
poisoned the country with hate
he had no choice larger fears of
incarceration did not work even for hate
crimes
however i understood i had a lot of
people that came to me and said you know
hate crimes are
on the increase and we are wary
that given the posture of the national
administration at the time
we were licensing so much hate and
racism
the message of lore and the consequences
at this point may be a message
that says that the hate crimes are okay
but that does sound
more like a political reasoning rather
than based on data no i mean look i made
it very clear
that the reasoning for doing this is
really was
you know it was one of messaging at the
moment uh
you know arguably you can say it was a
political thing but you know as
as an elected official um you know i am
working with the communities that i
represent
it's good to have reform it's good to
kind of deal with these issues
but if you go too far and you alienate
the public with these reforms
there is going to be a backlash and that
backlash
is never good while chase boudin's time
in san francisco may test the limits of
criminal justice reform it's
gascon's tenure in one of the world's
largest cities that could test the very
conceit of the progressive prosecutor
that social services can fix most or all
urban dysfunction
and that withholding police and
prosecutorial resources
can force the adoption of those
alternatives while he faces resistance
from law enforcement
city governments his own team of
prosecutors and the legal system itself
gascon remains committed to the idea
that broad systemic change is needed for
safety
and justice we are a country that has
increasingly become a country of half
and has not and you know you can travel
around the world those societies where
you have those extreme differences they
usually end up in revolutions or
dictatorships
the democratic system is not equipped to
cope with that the successful
democracies in the world are the ones
where you shrink
that difference between those that have
incredible wealth and those that do not
and that creates some level of
safety net public health and in those
societies you see not only greater
levels of security and public safety
but you see a greater level of
satisfaction across the board both for
those that are affluent and those that
are not